[Musique]
alors je vais faire mon monde je vais
parler en français est-ce que vous avez
déjà remarqué que quand vous avez un
problème vous êtes concentré sur ce
problème
ce problème bouffe votre ville ou votre
quotidien vous ne fait qu'y penser
est-ce que vous avez déjà remarqué que
comme par hasard beaucoup d'autres
problèmes arrivent derrière ça vous est
jamais un v6 voilà tout sa ligne tout sa
ligne on appelle ça au cameroun du doute
ou la sorcellerie baloc le sont envoyés
par le voisin qui est trop jaloux en
fait non il ya une explication très
rationnel très crédible à ce qu'ils se
battent c'est ce qu'on appelle en
d'autres termes la loi de murphy
la loi de murphy veut que quand quelque
chose va mal tout ce qui est lié à cette
chose où tout ce qui est dans votre vie
va aussi mal en somme les problèmes
viennent en légions pourquoi parce que
lorsqu'on a un problème est qu'on est
concentré sur ce problème
notre cerveau notre esprit est modifié
de manière à penser négativement
et quand on pense négativement on attire
des choses négatives
c'est scientifiquement prouvé donc
l'exercice
lorsqu'on a un problème est de rester
concentré de rester focus de manière à
pouvoir voir tout ce qu'il ya autour de
nous imaginez vous aller puiser de l'eau
vous casser la ans de votre saut comment
ce que vous allez faire pour puiser
l'eau
il n'y a pas de solution si vous êtes
concentré sur la hanche cassée et que
vous vous asseyez pour pleurer vous
n'aurez pas d'eau alors que si vous êtes
concentré sur trouver une solution aller
chercher une corde à côté allez demander
un saut à des voisins
alors pour épuiser votre eau et vous
pourrez rentrer à la maison pour faire
vos tâches ménagères par exemple
j'applique ce principe à l'économie du
pays
au cameroun nous avons tendance à penser
négativement
parce que l'économie est morose parce
qu'il n'ya pas assez de places en
amphithéâtre
parce qu'on ne mange d'ailleurs pour
certains pas toujours trois fois par
jour ou un autre fin alors on pense
négativement on pense qu'il n'y a pas
d'issue
on pense qu'il n'y a pas de solution je
vais vous prendre l'exemple d'une jeune
fille j'allais souvent dans une
entreprise et je rencontrais une jeune
fille qui avait qu'à 25 ans a gagné 75
lt réceptionner ses gammes 75 mille
francs par mois environ à l'époque
c'était ya à peu près deux ans a gagné
75 mille francs par mois
elle était souvent un peu renfrogné le
visage fermé un jour j'avais une attente
plus longue
on a décidé de discuter et quand on a
parlé elle m'a expliqué que elle n'était
pas contente de son travail mais le thé
contente d'avoir un minimum
elle n'était pas contente de ce qu'elle
avait fait mais elle était contente
d'être réceptionné ce talent je disais
mais qu'est ce que tu as fais dans la
vie
tenez vous bien elle avait un master en
mathématiques c'était une
mathématicienne qui gagné 75 mille
francs par mois et elle m'a expliqué
le problème c'est que je n'ai aucune des
bouchers tout le monde dans mon
environnement m'a toujours dit on ne
peut rien faire avec un master en
mathématiques dans ce pays ça ne sert à
rien de te prendre la tête donc oublier
trop font un petit travail elle s'est
trouvé ce travail et elle y était il
s'avérait que des partenaires à
l'entreprise croit pas que je gère il
s'avérait que des partenaires avaient un
programme de formation pour des femmes
aux cours du soir en informatique pour
en faire des co 2 je l'inscris c'était
il ya deux ans donc je disais
aujourd'hui elle travaille dans une
multinationale et gagne à peu près cinq
fois son salaire et l et al qods
donc elles utilisent au quotidien les
mathématiques
j'ai mis un mois à la convaincre de
quitter ses idées négatives embrasser
des idées positives pour se dire qu'elle
pouvait définitivement est arrivé est ce
que vous vous rendez compte quand on
calcule elle gagne plus elle a quitté
ces sites est négative
elle a des idées positives aujourd'hui
on gagne plus elle apporte plus à
l'entreprise qu'elle a elle forme
d'autres personnes elle a un meilleur
pouvoir d'achat donc elles consomment
plus dans la société
elle a un réel impact sur la société
on est passé de penser qu'on ne peut pas
à penser qu'on peut avoir un impact réel
si maintenant nous nous y mettons tous
si nous nous y mettons plus ou moins
tous si nous décidons que nous allons
avoir des pensées positives et donc
suivre les formations adéquates
appliquer ces formations adéquates au
quotidien si nous pensons qu'avec mes
pensées positives nous sommes capables
de réinventer et de réécrire notre
histoire tous les jours c'est nous
pensons qu'avec cette pensée positive
nous sommes en capacité d'être ce que
nous rêvons depuis que nous sommes
petits et le professeur l'a bien
expliqué tout à l'heure si nous pensons
que nous pouvons atteindre nos objectifs
alors nous pouvons atteindre nos
objectifs nous sommes combien dans cette
salle nous sommes à peu près 100 si une
deux trois quatre cinq dix personnes
changent ses pensées change sa vie
dix personnes apporteront beaucoup plus
à l'environnement est beaucoup plus au
pays
samse beaucoup plus profonde que ça de
penser positivement
ça m'a beaucoup plus loin d'avoir un
impact sur l'économie du pays
ça va à ces jeunes filles qui se disent
après avoir fait un bac de secrétariat
qu'elles ne veulent pas forcément être
cvt à et que le plus simple c'est
d'aller dans la rue c'est d'être avec un
monsieur qui gagnent beaucoup d'argent
ça va beaucoup plus loin d'avoir des
pensées positives ça apporte de l'espoir
ça apporte de la vie alors vous me direz
marylène c'est un peu facile pour toi
lui dit qu'on doit penser positivement
ça a l'air d'avoir une vie
voici la plus simple tu es là tu te
plantes devant nous tu as vécu à
l'étranger petit revient avec des idées
de blanc dans notre pays vous nous dit
comment est ce qu'on lui doit beaucoup
moi ma vie c'est la laisse alors nom n'a
pas été facile je suis partie conçu
partis à l'étranger
mon premier et mon premier stage d'abord
puis puis emploi je les trouvais chez
puma alors je n'avais pas les
qualifications nécessaires
j'ai commencé à coder j'ai appris à
coder pour créer un petit site web pour
envoyer mon cv peut être un peu pour
avoir l'air original c'était à peu près
en 2008 pour avoir l'air un peu original
donc j'ai envoyé mon cv à plusieurs
entreprises les entreprises comme
christian dior ralph lauren et ses
hommes ont contacté et je disais deux
parties chez puma parce qu'ils ont
organisé la première coupe du monde en
afrique
et c'était juste génial je suis allé là
bas c'est horrible certains moments me
demandait de m'aliéner suis une somme
très intéressant cependant quand j'ai vu
ce stage une amie est venue me voir il
m'a dit mais comment est ce que tu as
fait pour avoir ce stage puis ce travail
moi je suis dans une entreprise
spécialiste dans une école spécialisée
mais je cherche je ne trouve pas parce
que je pensais que je ne pouvais y
arriver je les trouvais j'ai foncé
après ça je suis allé au figaro le
figaro qui est l'un des plus grands on
va dire journaux au monde mais qui est
plutôt axé droite anti-immigrés anti un
peu noire anti et cetera mais qu'il y
avait beaucoup d'attractivité pour moi
donc je suis allé au figaro et j'ai vu
une annonce passée sur twitter je me
suis connecté sur twitter j'ai vu une
annonce passée j'ai saisi l'occasion
j'ai postulé et puis je suis allé dans
mon université donc c'est à l'université
de bordeaux et puis j'ai montré à la
gamme voilà j'ai un g1 j'ai un stage qui
peut déboucher sur un cdd
et au figaro lamara m'a dit mais comment
ça c'est pas possible
juste mais si c'est possible annonce
voisine ici là on n'a jamais travaillé
avec ce genre d'entreprise commencent à
ce que toi tu vas travailler avec ce
genre d'entreprise elle a traîné pour
faire les papiers puis à un moment je
m'appelle et me dit écoutez je suis
désolé mais là là là ça traîne trop ça à
pâques possible pour vous je suis parti
à paris suis allé leur parler je leur ai
dit je serai le meilleur candidat que
vous aurez ayez un peu de patience
ils ont eu de la patience je me suis
retrouvé là bas et quand j'entre au
figaro j'ai un cousin qui m'accueille
les qui me dis donc t'as dû faire jouer
beaucoup de contacts médias oui j'ai
fait jouer twitter c'est mon principal
contact on passe et puis on se retrouve
donc dans une agence je me retrouve dans
une agence de communication
quand j'entre dans cette agence je suis
payé ce qu'on appelle là-bas le smic
en gros mon loyer et mes charges dépassé
l'argent que j'ai gagné en entreprise je
marchais tous les jours pour aller au
travail ce n'était pas très loin
heureusement mais je marchais pour aller
au travail et je suis lisait tous les
jours quasiment à 22 heures je le disais
tout pas mal nous nous a je pense que
toi tu es plus riche que moi à la fin du
mois sa maman je te donne de l'argent
parce que je finis ta on s'était
quasiment le temps parce que des fois il
me prêtait notre marge
donc j'y suis allé j'ai foncé j'ai gardé
mes pensées positives et quand je suis
sorti de là ça n'a pas été facile a
offert mon morceau net ça n'a été facile
ce n'est jamais facile pour personne ce
n'est pas facile de se dit que quand on
vient de loin on va manger tous les
jours ce n'est pas facile de se dire
qu'on va atteindre cet objectif et ce
n'est pas facile de suivre
on va rencontrer des gens
extraordinaires pourtant rencontre des
gens extraordinaires
après j'ai monté mon entreprise quand
j'ai monté mon entreprise et je suis
venu au cameroun tout le monde m'a dit
écoute c'est bien c'est gentil c'est
sympa mais toi tu es étranger ils font
rentrer de là où tu viens tu n'es pas
camerounaise du battu pour me faire une
place
après je suis allé en côte d'ivoire
arrivé en côte d'ivoire j'étais très
contente miracle ivoirien c'est super on
va faire beaucoup de super affaire je me
suis fait qu'embrouiller quatre fois en
un an
c'était super dont une fois où je me
suis retrouvé avec le monsieur en
caleçon dans mon juste en caleçon dans
mon salon qui venait prendre mon
ordinateur dit bon écoute j'ai pris un
merci puis je suis rentré au cameroun
définitivement et blanc du chiot
cameroun et je vois que tout le monde
est un peu négatif mais je voulais vous
dire les années soit en positif ça ont
tous positifs
ben non ce n'est pas facile ce n'est pas
celle pour personne mais bâton
parce que si chacun d'entre vous se bat
aujourd'hui
alors tous ensemble on peut créer une
nation on a un pouvoir extraordinaire et
le pouvoir extraordinaire que nous avons
hommes comme femmes c'est de créer un
pays qui va au delà des espérances que
nous avons
[Applaudissements]